he told me you was he was going with
Matt Williams for a
time you talk too
much I don't talk too
much thinking who I got to beat in this
horse race that's
all I didn't realize this was a
race
I don't care for watching
horses well I'm a different kind of
horse what was
that that's how you are I don't know
what you said but it must have been
Indian for handsome
[Laughter]
devil
all
right I am an oage
Brave the long long time ago we oage
took our name from Missouri and oage
rivers
Nea Children of the middle
Waters move said the great white father
from Missouri from
Arkansas from
Kansas finally another Strange
Land Oklahoma where famine walked by day
and hungry wolves By
Night can you find the wolves in this
picture all right let's
go oh Sage weren't ever part of the Five
Civilized Tribes remember Blacky
Thompson howy boys of the Five Civilized
Tribes the Cherokee
Chickasaw
choc Creek
and
seol don't
[Music]
move Ooh That Rock still shines in the
dark boy give me here just take the car
don't take my ring my father gave it to
me don't want the car just want the
jewels I didn't do nothing to earn this
anyway you like these got us some rich
Indians
boys come
on come on come on I'm going all in boys
what you thinking Ernest
[Music]
no crazy Ernest I love money I Love
Money turn that card over boom yeah hell
yeah
Dan Queen gets
the Dawn was always a sacred time for
prayers
they call the sun
grandfather Moon
mother
fire
father they call it the flower moon when
tiny flowers spread over the Blackjack
Hills and the Prairies there are many so
many it's as if wont looked down upon
the Earth smiled and sprinkled it with
sugar
candy
Waka
wakon means
God you are given your oage
name it's how you will be called to the
next
World your oage name can never be taken
away from you way
[Applause]
aha here put this
on
you want
dinner
yeah
don't you want to bite of this I got too
much
sugar can never be too sweet now can
you makes me
sickly you live in this house just just
for your
mother I take care for
her you live with your uncle yes yes you
know since I can
remember he's a nice
man
why did you come here for
what to live here yes I live
here
why oh uh for my
uncle I work with
him your brother is Brian Barn that's
right
Baron you scared of
him my brother who your
uncle well
no no he's a he's the king of the oage
hills he's the nicest man in the world I
know if you cross him what he could
do now
I'm My Own man I do my own
work I'm a
businessman
thanks there you
go what's your
religion
Catholic you don't come to
church yes I I've been
away how come you don't have a
husband I'm a man I want to know why
woman like you doesn't have a
husband you know you got you got nice
color
skin
what what color would you say that
is my
color I think
it's I think it's real
pretty you got nice color skin you you
got you got a nice
house I think you just pretend to be so
severe I bet you I bet you got a soft
Belling on the inside
there see oh you just called me a coyote
didn't
you
coyote coyote wants
money